the fastpaced world of social media has
us scrolling relentlessly has us posting
incessantly has us chasing virality but
what if we worked harder on our
character than we did on our content I
see people announcing they're starting a
YouTube channel but I actually think
that doing the opposite is where the
real power is Proverbs 14:23 that it
says all hard work brings profit but
mere talk leads only to
poverty in this episode of the think
media podcast we're going to be talking
about three big ideas and some essential
scriptures that every Christian business
owner and Christian content creator
needs to know and I believe that this
episode will be encouraging and
challenging and will ultimately help you
grow your channel faster your brand
faster your business faster now this
episode's also brought to you by expand
Goods kingdom.com but a little bit more
on that later that's our updated class
for Christian content creators it's in
the show notes but let's dive into big
idea number one your long-term brand is
more important than short-term money
Proverbs 221 says a good name is more
desirable than great riches to be
esteemed is better than silver or gold
you know what is a brand ultimately a
brand is just a name with a story
attached atted to it when you think
about the name Henry Ford you think
about Ford Motorcars now Ford is a brand
name but it all started from a Visionary
and an innovator and a builder creating
something that established that brand
when you think about Ralph Lauren that's
a name associated with fashion and
clothing when you think about the name
Bernie made off you think Ponzi scheme
scam artist all the good that he did in
his life if any you forget about all of
that and what is remembered is his name
what's his brand scam artist and one of
the most important things we should be
considering as content creators is what
is the brand that we're building online
what is our personal brand what is our
business brand what is the story that
people think about when they think about
us now if you're just starting people
aren't attaching a story to your brand
yet but here's the challenge you get to
write that story every decision every
video every social media post actually
is adding up over time to the cumulative
brand that you're building and Proverbs
28:2 says this a trustworthy person will
get a rich reward but a person who wants
quick riches will get into trouble so I
think the Bible would encourage us that
your long-term brand is more important
than short-term money it's much more
valuable to have trust and integrity
over time and we will be richly rewarded
as opposed to chasing short-term money
quick riches that ultimately lead us
into trouble or tearing down our brand
people ask how long does it take to
build trust trust could take months it
could take years it could even take
decades to build substantive trust how
long does it take to destroy trust one
action One Moment One Night one event
Proverbs 28:20 says committed and
persistent work pays off getrich quick
schemes are ripoffs and Richard Branson
said this your brand or your name is
simply your reputation you have to fight
in life to protect that as it means
everything nothing is more important so
what does this mean practically as
content creators I think one not doing
brand deals and sponsorships that you
don't believe in two chasing Trends just
for views as opposed to you actually
caring about the trend three doing
Partnerships or collaborations with
people for clout alone looking past
maybe values or beliefs or things you
don't align with when it comes to that
individual four things that seem too
good to be true getting excited about
people that are promising big but not
doing your due diligence and research
and fully vetting the relationship the
vendor the software the tool a good name
is more desable than great riches and a
good name a strong brand takes years to
build and I think that this is not just
about what are you avoiding so you don't
hurt your brand it's also what do you
want to be known for what do you want
people to feel when they watch your
content What story do you want to be
told about you about your business about
your ministry about your church
ultimately you in partnership with God
and the Holy Spirit have a chance to
write that story your decisions your
choices your actions your content your
words your collaborations your
relationships all get added together to
make up your brand and I think one of
the principles that we can apply to this
big idea of your long-term brand is more
important than short-term money is the
challenge to work harder on your
character than you do on your content
the fastpaced world of social media has
us scrolling relentlessly has us posting
incessantly has us chasing virality and
all of those things are the activities
that a content creator engages in but
what if we worked harder on our
character than we did on our content
remember Proverbs told us AUST
trustworthy person gets a rich reward
who's a trustworthy person a person that
follows through on their word a person
who yes is yes and whose no is no one of
the things that I find fascinating is
that consistency is actually an
attribute of strong character think
about somebody in your life that has
strong character they're Dependable
they're consistent in their
encouragement and their attitude and
their emotions they you can count on
them to be present you know one of the
things that's disruptive for children if
there's inconsistency at home
inconsistency in is Dad G to be mean or
nice when he comes home from work
inconsistency is Dad going to be sober
or drunk inconsistency the opposite
would be consistency the person
continues to show up they continue to
deliver think about this in business the
person continues to make a promise
deliver on their promise follow up
deliver support there's consistent
interactions with that business now
let's apply this to YouTube are you
being consistent one of the attributes
of strong character is being consistent
did you make a promise on your YouTube
cover image on the banner and say new
uploads every week and if we go to your
channel and we see that the last upload
was 3 months ago that's inconsistency
now listen relax I'm not you're like
Sean you're stepping on my toes you're
calling me out you might have gone
through a season and we all have
challenges but if you want to be taken
seriously and you want to build a strong
brand and you want to build a strong
online business and you have the
audacity to want to work from home and
do this full-time there's something
about understanding that consistency is
an attribute of strong character about
having a consistent message having
consistent values that show up in your
content following through on your
promises I promise you I'm going to
create this product or this service or
this membership site or this patreon and
I'm going to keep showing up and keep
following through with consistency
number one big idea your long-term brand
is more important than shortterm money
have you made an offer or a promise or
you stretched yourself but then you
realized you couldn't follow through
later in Luke Jesus gave three examples
and he said why would someone set out to
build a tower without F first assessing
if they had enough money and resources
to complete it they would only get
halfway done and then people would laugh
at them when they were halfway done
there's something about being
disciplined and diligent and protective
of your name of your brand because your
long-term brand is more important than
shortterm money big idea number two say
less do more what do I mean Proverbs
14:23 says this all hard work brings a
profit but mere talk leads only to
Poverty have you ever had a friend or a
family member who talks big but does
little maybe you have somebody that you
know that's like always talking about
what they're going to do the dreams that
they have things that they're going to
accomplish things that they want to try
you know ultimately if you're just
hanging out with friends and just
talking about dreams and just kind of
passing some time you know that's fine
but I find it fascinating in Proverbs
1423 that it says hard work all hard
work brings profit but mere talk leads
only to Poverty like you could talk
about going to your actual job but if
you don't actually go to your job work
hard then you don't get a paycheck
because you didn't show up to work and
so mere talk means you don't get paid
whereas taking action and putting in the
work means you do and so I feel like
this verse tells us don't just talk
about it be about it actions speak
louder than words say less and do more
one of the things that's funny about
social media is announcement posts I see
people announcing they're starting a
YouTube channel they do a little text
post posted on Instagram they go on X
they do do a post you know this is what
I'm thinking about doing this quarter
they go to Facebook and they make an
announcement now do whatever you want
but I actually think that doing the
opposite is where the real power is like
don't tell anybody about what you're
doing just go do it and don't don't
publicly Proclaim anything just go do it
here's why because if you make a
proclamation I'm starting a YouTube
channel I'm starting a weekly show I'm
starting a video podcast and then you
don't follow through you can count on me
for every you know week it's when Jesus
said let your yes be yes and your no be
no it's just being careful with the
Declarations we're making and if you
don't say it I know that saying it could
produce some accountability and you're
trying to hold yourself publicly
accountable but there's just something
about saying less and doing more rather
than taking time to make the
announcement post go start building your
YouTube channel don't just talk about it
be about it and scripture even reveals
that talking about it can sometimes be
harmful you know in Genesis 37
Joseph's mistake was talking about his
dream with the wrong people Joseph whose
Dad gives him this Technicolor coat also
has some dreams that eventually his
family and his brothers will be bowing
down to him because he'll be in a place
of rulership and they will be in a place
of ultimately in servitude of the
authority and the position that he's in
so he tells his family about his dream
the dream made it sound like Joseph was
going to rule over his family and guess
what happened his brothers weren't
pumped and excited about his dream and
his future and this aspiration and this
is so cool oh my gosh that sounds
amazing no his brothers became angrier
they were already mad that he seemed to
have a little bit of favoritism from his
father they got even madder angrier and
they didn't like his dreams what's the
principle don't be surprised if you
don't get affirmation and encouragement
when pursuing your dreams don't be
surprised if you make declarations about
what you're going to do and people don't
support you they might be insecure they
might be jealous they might doubt your
ability to pull it off they might want
to protect you from disappointment
they've got good intentions but here's
the problem if it's authentically your
dream if it's something that's truly on
your heart if you say man I'm sick of
this job I'm sick of this corporate 9
to-5 I'm sick of this boss that I hate
I'm sick of my current circumstances in
life right now I want to work from home
I want to tap into the crater economy I
really care about my mission and my
cause and I want to build a YouTube
channel I want to reach more people for
my nonprofit I want to do this thing
I've got this aspiration I've got this
dream all hard work brings a profit
start building but mere talk leads to
Poverty sharing with others might not
lead to the support that ultimately
you're looking for and some good
intentioned people that ultimately want
to protect you from disappointment may
speak words of death into your dream
this is an area that you got to
personally process because of course
getting feedback and being surrounded by
people that can help you see your blind
spots is a powerful principle that can
protect us from going down a path we
shouldn't pursue on the flip side
there's so many stories of people who
nobody around them saw the dream saw the
vision as is often the case for
Visionaries and if you're listening to
this you probably are one you see a
vision that people don't see leaders see
more and they see before I heard John
Maxwell say that they see further they
see things other people don't see don't
be surprised when you see the
possibility on YouTube the possibility
of passive income the possibility of
growing you're starting to understand
the algorithm you're seeing the
opportunity with content creation and
then you talk about it with your spouse
and they don't see it it's a vision that
you've seen it's a picture that you see
so you got to be careful it's like when
Mary said she pondered these things in
her heart there was certain things that
were happening supernaturally in her
life that she didn't necessarily talk
about with with everybody else I just
want to encourage you big principle
number two say less do more all hard
work brings a profit but mere talk leads
to poverty and the bottom line is that
if you have a dream if you have a vision
if you have a desire to step out step up
and to build something to do this thing
then ultimately just get to work and
start doing it which brings us to number
three slow and steady wins here's what
Proverbs 13311 says wealth gained
hastily will dwindle but whoever gains
little by little will increase it so
there's not a lot of people that are
shouting down the preacher for this
verse in a 2024 World we're living in a
world of viral success of seemingly
overnight success of stories we see on
social media of hypergrowth companies of
all of these different people around us
that we could compare ourselves to and
get discouraged by when
ultimately ancient wisdom from King
Solomon and the Book of Proverbs says
that if we're gaining wealth with haste
we read a few verses earlier about
getrich quick schemes that that wealth
will dwindle but that ultimately whoever
gathers little by little will increase
it my experience after being on YouTube
for 17 years has taught me but that this
is true about building a channel as well
that you can go viral with one video but
still not ultimately build a career and
ultimately go full-time on YouTube that
you can have 15 of Fame on social media
but not build an actual Legacy or a
viable business there's something about
building little by little there's
something about one video at a time
getting 1% better with every upload
adding to your skill set one skill at a
time with marginal but continuous
improvements that leads to massive
success over time and Proverbs 20:21
says an inheritance obtained too early
in life is not a blessing in the end
which scenario would you rather have
would you rather gain your inheritance
early wealth Fame prestige your YouTube
channels blowing up but at the end of
your life or five or 10 years later it
was all gone and behind you was a trail
of Ruin or would you rather have not a
lot of Fame not a lot of money not a lot
of success in the first three years five
years let's say even 10 years how about
15 how about 20 what if you had 20 years
of obscurity let's say 20 to 40 years
old 20 years of some impact you survived
but no crazy fireworks in your life in
your business and your YouTube channel
but then from year 40 to 50 50 to 60 60
to 70 with Medical Treatments and
healthc Care 70 to 80 80 to 90 you're
flourishing more than ever and you have
life long success impact Legacy great
things take time and great things take
patience this is a mentality that I
think Keeps Us anchored this is a spirit
filled mentality this is a Biblical
mentality slow and steady winds you see
it everywhere you see this backside of
the desert 40 years Moses being
developed before he end up going and
being the deliverer you do see wandering
in the desert for 40 years a lot of
people perished But ultimately Caleb and
Josh had to wait and then they got to go
to the promised land you see even Jesus
himself having a pretty lowkey life not
a lot that we have recorded about his
early life besides when he was in the
temple at 12 and then boom he's 30 and
his ministry starts this is
developmental Years Years where he's
probably working as a stonemason or a
carpenter just doing the small things
well just being consistent just building
up his character building up his skills
growing in wisdom and stature being in
that season where it FS lonely and
you're not being seen and you wish it
was growing faster and you wish the
results were coming faster but friend
slow and steady wins and wealth gained
hastily will dwindle but whoever gathers
little by little will increase it it's
almost like God knew cuz he does know
that for us to be able to Steward and
manage the potential wealth and Prestige
and fame and awareness and significance
that can come our way on the other side
of building a successful YouTube channel
could crush us
because if we gain it hastily it'll
dwindle we might break an inheritance
gained too early in the beginning won't
be blessed in the end but if we get if
we grow it little by little there's
another verse talks about that that's
how they took the promised land little
by little and if they cleared the
promised land too quickly then the wild
beast would come back and would like eat
your family like you look that one up
later like you don't want your family to
get eaten by wild beasts you want to
grow little by little and Galatians 69
says this let's not get tired of doing
good because in time we'll have a
harvest if we don't give up so I want to
encourage you don't get tired and doing
good your long-term brand is more
important than shortterm money say less
and do more and slow and steady wins and
if you've liked this episode of the
podcast I think you're going to love the
free class that I just shot just
recorded at expand good kingdom.com it's
about a 90minut class where I talk about
my system for Success growing a YouTube
channel but I also tie it into a lot of
scriptures Bible verses as well as hard
one strategies and tactics that I've
learned in my career of getting three
silver play buttons a gold play button
growing multiple channels and so it's
entirely free it's at expand Gods
kingdom.com where you can watch that
class on demand and I'm also curious if
you do watch the video version of this
podcast smash like and leave me a
comment of your takeaways or any
questions you have maybe as a Christian
content creator or business owner that
you like me to cover in future episodes
if you listen on audio best way to give
feedback is to rate and review the
podcast and leave a review on Apple
podcast if you want to leave a review
and fire off a question or a topic I do
review those so I would love to connect
with you there as well and I also want
to encourage you check out the playlist
of other episodes in this series for
Christian content creators and Christian
business owners we'll also link that up
in the show notes my name is Sean canel
rhymes with YouTube channel and I can't
wait to connect with you in a future
episode so